[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i am going
to explain an american comedy film
called billy madison spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
billy madison is a spoiled 27 year old
man child all he does is drink play
silly pranks with his friends and stare
at nude magazines for hours he hasn't
grown a day since middle school much to
his father brian's annoyance brian is
the founder of one of the largest
restaurant chains in the u.s he always
had the wish to pass down his fortune to
his son but because of billy's lifestyle
he is rethinking the decision one day
brian invites his business associates
for dinner at his house two of the
guests at the dinner are the company's
executive vice president eric and
operations manager carl eric and carl
are close to brian and help him make all
the important decisions about the
company brian wants to officially
announce his retirement but billy
interrupts him every time he starts to
talk eric doesn't like billy and does
everything he can to keep him childish
so he won't be appointed as chairman of
the company he makes faces at billy
making him yell gibberish in the end
brian yells at billy to get out
following that he goes out with his
friends to a fast food restaurant as
usual they talk like kids and prank
older people back in the mansion eric
lays down all the childish things that
billy has said and done and convinces
brian he isn't eligible to take over the
business carl on the other hand claims
that there is still hope for billy but
eric dismisses him in reality he wants
to be promoted as the president so he is
doing everything in his power to remove
his biggest competition later at night
brian calls billy to his study room to
inform him of something big he reveals
that he has decided to hand the business
over to eric who he thinks is the most
competent and capable of being president
billy is in shock because his father has
never refused to give him something let
alone their family business he argues
that eric is cruel and uncaring but
brian is adamant about his decision he
reveals that back when billy was in high
school he had bribed the high school
teachers to give him passing grades not
just that but every grade billy ever
passed was because brian somehow bribed
the teacher including the second grade
where he spelled back as b-a-k and still
passed since billy isn't even a high
school graduate there is no room for him
to go against the decision desperate to
be heard billy proposes a deal to his
father he promises to study in each
grade of school for two weeks and pass
them all if he manages to do so brian
will be sure of his worthiness and hand
the company over to him but if he
doesn't eric will be named the president
brian likes the idea and makes some
calls to get his son into the first
grade the next day the housemaid juanita
makes billy a lunch box and sends him
off to catch the school bus he waits for
it but the bus passes him by without
stopping when he reaches the school with
his father the first person he sees is
the third grade teacher veronica she
recognizes billy as the spoiled rich kid
and instantly dislikes him following the
brief encounter billy goes to his class
and meets his new little friends he gets
along with them pretty quickly because
even though he is older his personality
is no different from theirs they listen
to stories play dodgeball sleep during
nap time and do the regular things that
first graders do after school a kid's
mother comes to pick him up and flirts
with billy she is even more intrigued
when her son informs her that he is his
classmate the next two weeks are fun for
billy he makes friends with everyone in
the class and is well liked by his
teacher miss lippy although he sometimes
accidentally eats glue fights with the
kids about video games and has problems
using the children's urinals he is
overall happy after drawing a blue duck
on a drawing test he passes first grade
and throws a huge graduation party for
his friends the party has a pinata
stuffed with rolex watches and expensive
chocolates his father who had no faith
in billy is pleasantly surprised that he
passed the only person not pleased about
him passing the grade is eric he has
even appointed the school's janitor to
keep an eye on billy the second grade is
more difficult than he had thought
especially because of the spelling tests
billy goes against a little girl in a
spelling competition which he wins after
spelling the word couch correctly
because of the win he passes and throws
an even bigger party he invites all of
his friends and plays with them on water
slides eric is also at the party and is
planning to do something big to make
billy fail finally in the third grade
veronica turns out to be his teacher
although she picks on him and doesn't
really like him billy is motivated to go
to school just to see her he creates
trouble in her class simply to be
noticed making it clear that he likes
her one day she finds him drawing
pictures of half-naked girls in his
notebook to teach him a lesson she asks
him to write a few words on the board in
cursive handwriting he does pretty well
for the first few words but cannot seem
to write the letter z correctly veronica
makes fun of him in front of the entire
class and humiliates him billy bursts
out shouting that he hates them all and
runs home the next morning he pretends
to be sick so he won't have to go to
school again but the maid juanita tells
him that he will have to help her shave
her armpit if he stays home billy
reluctantly goes to school not wanting
to face veronica again to his luck she
calls in sick that very day in her place
the principal of the school mr anderson
takes the class during recess billy
receives several cards since it is also
valentine's day he is the coolest guy in
the class and is liked by many girls
after school billy and his third grade
friend ernie hang out at his house billy
misses veronica and asks ernie to call
her to see if she likes him too ernie
talks to her normally before asking her
if she would date anyone from their
class veronica calls billy immature and
ends the phone call the next day is the
school field trip on their way to the
location some guys dare billy to touch
veronica's chest he happily accepts the
challenge and pretends to fall on top of
her veronica on the other hand playfully
calls him out for it as the kids laugh
at him later billy apologizes to her for
what happened and she forgives him then
he notices ernie standing alone in a
corner and finds out that he has wet his
pants to help his friend billy also wets
his crotch and claims that peeing
yourself is cool all the children follow
his lead and wet their pants one after
another after seeing him help ernie
veronica starts to like billy in the
following scene billy throws a third
party on passing the third grade this
one is even bigger than the former two
parties combined kids run around the
huge park that he has arranged in front
of his mansion veronica also comes to
the party and gives him snack packs as a
graduation gift billy shows her around
as they talk about different things they
eventually end up inside a tent and are
about to kiss when carl interrupts them
he warns billy of eric who is planning
something for his downfall billy thanks
him for the warning but doesn't think
much of it starting that day he studies
hard and passes the next four grades
without any problem it has been a while
since he met veronica so he kisses her
picture when he misses her he is still
best friends with the third grade
students and hangs out with them during
the lunch break they often invite him to
play soccer but the more he is promoted
to upper grades the busier he gets when
he passes the eighth grade he organizes
yet another party to celebrate his entry
to high school the school's principal mr
anderson meets eric in private during
the party eric has done some digging and
found out about anderson's double life
turns out that he used to be a wrestler
who accidentally killed a man by sitting
on him for too long if people find out
about this he will lose his job as the
principal eric takes advantage of this
situation and blackmails him he wants
anderson to spread a rumor that billy
bribed him to pass the tests with no
other way out mr anderson agrees to the
lie the next day is billy's first day in
high school the last time he was in high
school billy was one of the popular guys
he had thought that it would be the same
this time around as well but in contrast
no one pays attention to him during
chemistry class he makes obnoxious jokes
about the teacher but no one laughs a
girl even asks him to not talk to her
because he is a loser and she doesn't
want to be made fun of
one of the cool kids drops curry on top
of his head billy misses his third
grader friends and goes to meet them
during recess when asked about high
school he lies and claims that everyone
is nice to him and he is having a great
time at home he realizes that when he
was popular he also bullied the
introverted kids he calls one of them
named danny and apologizes to him while
on the phone danny simply forgives him
but after the call he crosses out
billy's name from his people to kill
list later that day principal anderson
publicly announces that he was bribed by
billy to give him passing grades a
disappointed brian hands over the
company to eric and doesn't believe
billy when he tries to explain himself
billy loses all hope and returns to his
old lifestyle partying all the time and
pranking people veronica knows that he
worked hard for the grades hence she
picks him up one day and beats him
brutally trying to motivate him to not
give up without a fight meanwhile
billy's third grade friends protest
outside the principal's house forcing
him to come clean about billy's grades
and his lies after finding out the truth
brian is ready to give his son a second
chance to continue high school however
eric protests and claims that since
billy didn't complete the ninth grade in
two weeks he isn't eligible for the
company's presidency when brian still
doesn't side with him eric threatens to
sue him billy challenges him to an
academic decathlon to finally settle
their feud with the winner getting to
take over the business the next friday
they gather at school for the
competition while eric wins the math
test billy does great in the pie cooking
competition similarly both of them win
in some tests and lose in others by the
end of it billy is winning by a single
point the next day everyone gathers at
the auditorium for the final round that
will determine the winner billy is asked
a question about the industrial
revolution and replies with a completely
idiotic answer then eric is asked a
question regarding business ethics eric
being an unethical businessman has no
answer to the question on realizing that
he is about to lose he pulls out a
revolver ready to shoot billy dead he is
saved when anderson in wrestling gear
tackles eric after recovering from the
attack he attempts to shoot veronica but
before he can he is shot by dany whom
billy apologized to earlier for bullying
in the following scene billy is at his
graduation ceremony he announces that he
wants to pass the responsibility of his
father's business onto carl who is more
deserving than him billy also reveals
that he plans to attend college in order
to become a teacher
in the final scene we see eric walking
away from the ceremony on crutches while
the others celebrate
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching